the RNC is trolling Democrats for
appearing to come up short in Ohio's
12th district special election a race
that's still too close to call
close in Ohio 12 but no cigar at least
not yet this is a moral victory for the
Democrats the fact that they're this
close is a moral victory for the
Democrats you want a real victory we got
some mojo all right or whatever aural
victory moral victories moral victory
moral victory does not get you an office
Karl Rove reacting to the election
results by saying the Blue Wave could be
receding and Republicans have a fighting
chance to keep the House Majority this
comes as more Democrats are distancing
themselves from party Leader Nancy
Pelosi
would you back Pelosi for speaker if you
win and are in the house well I think
again we don't want to get ahead of
ourselves as you mentioned I gotta win
my race first but we got to take a look
at what's going on we got to take a look
at at winning the house back in November
and then once the house is won we have
to make that decision from there will
you vote for Nancy Pelosi probably not
probably not that's my answer no
probably not
she doesn't speak about the issues that
are important to the families of the 13
congressional district all right Jason
Nancy Pelosi has got a lot of too high
tolerance for this kind of thing she
doesn't ever get in the middle she just
lets them say what they want cuz she
wants to win oh she's keeping track
don't be fooling anybody and you know
what it is a legitimate question because
it's the very first thing you do as a
new member of Congress you have to go in
front of the entire body and call out
who is it that you're gonna vote for and
it the reality is the Democrats they
lack leadership I don't think they have
the right policies and to the point of
the the piece beforehand I don't think
there is some big wave that's coming
from the Democrats i sat there in 2010
and the year after the the election
after Barack Obama
they took I think it was a net of 63
seats that switched hands and there was
this big tsunami and I don't see any
evidence of it happening this time I was
so excited to talk politics I didn't do
what I meant to do which is to introduce
Morgan yeah
all of you into the very brutal I'm very
busy
known for that really to being very rude
Morgan welcome thank you that's a little
about yourself where you from
well I'm filled to be here I've been
watching this show for ages so I'm happy
to be here I live in New York City but
I'm from Florida I am in the US Navy
Reserves I've been stationed as a
civilian in Saudi Arabia at the US
Embassy there and in Baghdad I think
we've got some fun pictures of me
looking like a dork in my Kevlar and you
look safe actually that's not a very
graceful picture of me in the Saudi
Arabian desert that's a classic and this
is me getting promoted a couple years
ago Anchors Aweigh thank you and one of
my favorite things I'm an identical twin
$10 if you can guess which one is me in
or glacier you're on the left
nope wait totally different I moved to
New York in 2006 to work on Katie
McFarland's Senate races her press
secretary and Rollins brought me to New
York and I literally lived with Katie so
it's very incestuous Fox News with all
the connections also you had another
thing you said you and your grandfather
used to I said before the show that I
love her Aldo because I grew up with my
grandfather watching cable news and we
want but we watched the first Iraq war
with you reporting from both Iraq Wars
actually and big fan but I used to get
you know well the pretty girl said oh I
love you her elbow and the pretty girls
would say well my mother loves you her
although right now the pretty girls say
oh my grandmother loves Greg all the
older ladies love you
unlike the son they they allow to get
away with saying really awful things
like they would punish me if I was their
kid but they just treat me like always
he doesn't really mean that welcome to
you and thank you would you like to
comment on the state of the midterms so
it was interesting to me I was listening
to what they were saying moral victory
moral victory and I thought moral
victory is like the new liberal version
of participation trophy like you know
when you were kids I'm the resident
millennial on the panel so we were
Millennials you
we're kids we get participation
participation trophies if we didn't know
do well so I think as long as they want
to keep saying moral victory they can
have their participation trophy but
there's one winner there's one person
that gets sworn in and one person who's
not and it's a winner-take-all game I
did just say Geraldo that when reading
Karl Rove's call him this morning
reminded me of August of 2006 when I was
a deputy spokesperson and he was the
political director and deputy chief of
staff and I'd go in and say Carl they're
asking me again how you're feeling about
the midterms and he would tell me well
all these things are going in our
direction and till they weren't terms
are tough but thinking about moral
victories is and it's inching the
participation trophy I think of a moral
victory plus $2.75 gets you a token on
the subway the MTA card it is I think
the Democrats are facing a potential
problem with this division Alexandria
Ocasio Cortez we have been playing her
she's like the the best advertisement
for Republicans but cheese represents a
wing of the Democratic Party that's very
fervent energetic but it is not the
Nancy Pelosi mainstream wing let's get
things done there is a division within
the Democratic Party that I think bodes
well for Republicans I don't think Trump
or the Republicans are out of the woods
by any means but I do think that at this
stage with you know what is it less than
three months to go before the election
the Democrats could be far more United
far more formidable they have put up
some good channeling they say the guy
who ran against both us in Ohio good
Danny Boy was a good good candidate came
up short I think that there'll be some
marginal shifting as of right now if I
were handicapping I say it's basically a
wash will be a divided Cortes it's not
that conservatives are putting her on
television and interviewing her all the
time she's but the media has made her
yeah in this star exactly what what's
being done with her is what CNN did with
Trump and they shined a spotlight on on
this on this unusual character and they
laugh but remember who got the last
laugh it was it wasn't CNN it was Trump
so remember when you when you target
somebody often the target gets better
because they're listening and they
learned the miss
from the mistakes and they see what
works so she might and she might grow
because precisely because of the
sunlight as for the ad I want to ask you
one question sure and I don't mean to
cut you off but do you think a 50 year
old white guy is gonna vote for
Alexandria Ocasio Cortez under any
circumstances I work of course I don't
need any services but do you think that
that's really gonna happen sure why not
I don't see it well I think you asked
that question so you could answer that's
what Geraldo does no but I think in
terms of I I believe for the Democrats
moral victories are to them real
victories and I hope they're undefeated
with their moral victories because moral
victories will not come nominate a judge
it will not reverse any executive orders
you won't get to the White House on a
moral victory I'll take in a moral
victory over a moral loss Jason I want
you to listen to Andrew Cuomo he's
telling Democrats to be less negative
watch mm-hmm I would like to see the
Democratic Party frankly be less
negative because Trump is doing the best
negative case that we could ever do and
start to be more affirmative about what
the Democrats will do when we get in
power if you look back I believe that's
why the Democrats have lost in the past
we have not had a credible vision that
people believed would make their life
better and people have to believe you
can do it it can't be abstract
theoretical pie in the sky all right our
Democrats too negative well yes but they
don't have anything to go to they are
the resistance movement they are
scorched earth they want to raise your
taxes they want to give the gavel back
to Nancy Pelosi and if you ask yourself
over your home what do Democrats stand
for what do they really want to do the
answer is they want to get rid of the
tax cuts they want to go back to these
policies that don't make any sense I
don't think they have a positive message
and then the same Andrew Cuomo we're
gonna talk about it later and the show
goes out and says you know we I'm not
gonna cooperate with ice well that
doesn't it sound like somebody who's
trying to be positive the other thing
though Morgan is that as everybody
complains about negative ads but
negative ads work so if you're not in
power the only way to actually get your
men
such a cross is to say that the other
person is doing bad even if you want to
get a positive message out there in some
ways I guess Alexandria for example is
going out talking about medicare-for-all
free tuition those types of things looks
like a positive message but if you're an
independent voter it might be a negative
I just wish that people will get
comparing her to a beauty queen because
as a former beauty queen I can say that
everyone that I've worked with in the
Miss America system is a hell of a lot
smarter than her at least veteran state
because I think she's terrible on
television I mean look at the stuff that
she says she's terrible because she
hasn't thought through how to pay for
the wonderful programs that she keeps
proposed but there is no way to pay for
them without bound without bankrupting
the US government so listen but when it
what you're getting at is you know who's
motivated to come out to the polls in
November right that's the real question
and I think even if they don't have a
unifying message I do think that
Democrats are motivated to come out so I
think it's gonna be a really long
election night it's gonna be close in a
lot of districts but they while I don't
love the message I do think that they
are motivated and I think that's why
you're seeing the president get involved
in these primary races and the races
around the country because quite frankly
he is what is most unifying most
interesting because right before the
show term the president was during a
roundtable in New Jersey was talking
about prison reform and you would think
that most Democrats would agree with him
on that like want to come to the table
and actually work with him on that it's
something that actually could get done
it was it wasn't even a roundtable did
you notice that we do a rectangular
table we got it was a rectangle okay
ball yeah okay but what you're talking
about
are there the problems with the
Democratic Party it's not just the
negative messaging but also a lack of
ideas and so what the interesting thing
about Trump is that he's open to almost
any idea and I mean yourself that with
North Korea is the ultimate example of
being open to any idea and I think he
will be open to prison reform he's open
to even certain things about immigration
that I mean granting essentially amnesty
to over a million people I want to bring
up I like to you know I spend a lot of
time in pharmacies just for reasons that
I can't get into but a democrat party
when it comes to health care condoms
they were throwing they're throwing
socialism around because they don't have
any ideas meanwhile you look at CBS a
drugstore is unveiling a telemedicine
app right this is gonna allow you to go
and see a doctor via you know your your
your whatever screen you have that
solves health care not socialism not
free health care not you could give
Bernie sander trillions of dollars he
would not come up with an idea like
telemedicine this is going to be solved
all the problems are gonna be solved by
capitalism because capitalism replaces
force with innovation and the Democrats
are still stuck on force and they do and
they're scared of ideas and innovations
the problem is that no nobody on either
side of the aisle is gonna work with the
other side of the aisle infrastructure
for instance a no-brainer but the
private sector figures without like that
type of innovation you don't even have
to have health insurance you don't want
to pay out of your pocket for the
telemedicine from yes and that could
solve a lot of yeah but I mean not that
is the solution it is in socialism and
the Democrats came up with specific
ideas for once you know it would be kind
of encouraging just once give us one I'd
like all right one we'll see if they
hear you and if they respond with we
watch this show just one more idea all
right how about legalizing someone who's
been here for thirty years and their
citizen children well that was what Greg
just said that the president was open to
yeah what's going on that and you're
looking at you're looking at some pretty
progressive drug laws going on right now
yes you are